how do you do a mission impossible movie
you're on set
in italy i understand you guys are being
very careful
day to day do you know if you're allowed
to shoot or if the protocols change
how does that realistically happen
well we're just we're just working very
carefully with the authorities here and
if they do change their protocols then
we pause
and we we reposition and we
you know we we're just being an
abundance of caution is the kind of
the buzz phrase here and that's what
we're doing and i think you know
when this happened in february nobody
knew what was happening
we have more knowledge now and more
ability to kind of mitigate some of the
problems that it throws up so we're just
being super careful
um you talk about being super careful
and i'm sure that you are
uh with with kovid but you're also
working with
tom cruise you're working with tom
cruise on a mission impossible
movie and you talk about well we're
being very careful
and i know anyone who looks at a
magazine
has seen photographs of some of the
things that
we all know what he's done in the past
movies and we know that he likes to
notch it up each time
to the point where i don't think it's
possible he can notch it up anymore
and now i'm i'm hearing about these
insane stunts that tom cruise is doing
uh on the set of this movie are you
present when he does those stunts
yes and for us it's like i mean when you
watch the movie and you see him do those
stunts and it's nail-biting and there's
a real sense of
of genuine kind of um peril because you
know that it's him
but you know he survived because he was
on good morning america that morning and
he did some press
when we do it when we watch him do it we
have no idea if he if he's going to
survive
so he rides a bike off a cliff and
everyone's just waiting for
good canopy good canopy anybody anybody
because tom cruise
it's terrifying it's terrifying are you
with him before
he gets on the bike and does it does
anyone talk to him
uh and say like look it was nice knowing
you
you uh i'll pass on a message to anybody
you want to get to
yeah i mean he was hanging because he
loves it you know he puts in a lot of
work he trains
i mean he literally will become the best
at you tell him something and he'll just
become the best at it and it'll take
he'll take as many hours as it takes
but he won't do the stunt until he knows
i mean the prep that went into the big
stance for this film
are insane but i yeah we saw him just
before i remember when we did the last
one the big helicopter chase
um was gonna we were in new zealand and
myself and rebecca focused and we were
gonna go back to london and leave tom
and chris macquarie to do this big thing
and i said goodbye to tom and there was
a real kind of
then well good luck like not knowing if
if he was going to survive the next 10
days which was him
piloting a helicopter through these you
know these sort of glacial mountains it
was terrifying
yeah so uh you're there you're there
while it's happening
and we all know yeah like you say you
see him on good morning america which is
by the way that's how i determine if
someone's still alive every day
is i check good morning america
and if they're on it i know that they're
okay
you are are you a um you're an
adrenaline junkin
a junkie aren't you you're someone who
likes to try things
yeah i mean i like you know snowboarding
and i like things that
aren't necessarily lethal i mean the
stuff that tom does that goes that's off
the charts that's not adrenaline that's
some other hormone you only secrete
just before you die
[Laughter]
he's next level i i yeah i mean i'm i'm
always happy to do my own stunts in this
fortunately i'm the computer nerd you
know i just
i'm basically his gps and i just tell
him go left go right
jump off this cliff yeah so i'm happy
i'm happy there you know
yeah so the only thing that could really
go wrong for you is you might delete
some of your files that would be that's
that's the
yeah that's what's going to happen to
simon pegg on one of these movies is
uh he pressed ctrl alt 7 accidentally
and someone had to step in and correct
it i might accidentally
reveal my history on my web browser and
oh no don't look at that it's nothing
nothing at all